thanks for coming over here I realize
this is supposed to be a talk aimed at
the broad audience and that's what we
have here though I do see a number of
friends over here and I do hope you will
find something interesting nevertheless
in this talk I'm going to be assuming
very little and I'll be very honest
they'll you'll probably see very little
that's new nevertheless I think there is
some very interesting notion that we
have been sort of both the theories of
computer science and the theory of you
know Electrical Engineering which has
traditionally studied communication have
sort of left in between the two spaces
and there is room for us to expand and
cover more questions and themes in this
area so let me try jump ahead and try to
explain at least some of the ideas that
went into the stock that I'm preparing
what do I want to talk about I want to
talk about communication but through
throughout the stock communication
refers to digital communication
ideally communicating sort of bits by
its data etc etc not analog
communication that's not something that
we are - that's not our focus today and
the challenge is that communication
comes with lots of you know objectives
their communication can actually be
expensive when you have a satellite
going off into space and sending you
know beaming signals back to earth it's
actually expensive to communicate bits
it can be very noisy of course which
happens both with the satellite
communication setting or if you're
trying to store information which is
like communication over time I want to
store information today and recover it
and then year from now bits can get
flipped the DVDs that you put the
machine information on can get scratched
and more interesting aspects that we
will see later today in this talk is
communication is interactive and we
nearly decide to do things that are
interactive every one of these questions
that you're thinking about becomes a
little bit more you know more
challenging more complicated and a theme
that I definitely do want to get to
towards the end of the talk is that
are communicating today but they're also
at the same time computing in this
interaction between the ability to
compute versus the need to communicate
is always being somehow at odds with
each other and this is something that we
want to talk about a little bit now you
can ask the question why talk about
aetherium and computers are
communicating and they're doing pretty
well why you know why not just use
whatever works and I do want to
emphasize this this is a talk on theory
but there is a reason why theory is very
important in these kinds of settings so
ad hoc solutions work today but I don't
know how well they'll work tomorrow you
know so this has been a constant problem
with methods and solutions that we've
proposed for all kinds of engineering
problems including the setting of
communication where there's often
methods that we can figure out today
that will actually work fairly well on
the current instances that we are
looking at when we decide to say well
and suddenly when you sort of build the
protocol its deployed at you suddenly
realized oh there are unexpected
problems theory typically helps us
anticipate and address those things and
formulating a problem you know something
that I try to teach all my students is
you know before you give me the solution
tell me what was the problem that you're
trying to solve okay this is a very
important mantra and I think it's very
very important that we don't confuse the
two the solution is not the first thing
that you should be focusing on it's the
problem itself and sometimes once you
decide that you formulate the problem
very carefully you will find creative
solutions which sort of confound
surprise you you realize it's actually
well within the scope of what you were
allowed to do and so you can run with it
and hopefully you'll see some of the
effects of these things today sorry
something's
bothering me okay so and finally I mean
when you formulate problems carefully
you can actually understand the limits
and these limits are as important to us
as the ability to solve the problems up
to a certain point why can we not do
better and what are the barriers to
solving them better which might actually
just suggest a way to go around the
barrier understanding of limits is the
fundamental question and these are the
reasons why I think theory is important
and probably you know preaching to the
masses over here preaching to the
converted folks so nevertheless I think
it's good to keep these in mind as we
figure out so I'm sorry I'm having a
little bit of a problem with the clicker
so I'm gonna try see if I can fix this
all right so and finally I said you know
old and new community theories why new
theory is why with old ones somehow
lacking in some aspect and quite
interestingly I think over here it's
it's a case of not quite that but
exactly the opposite problem the old
ones were so good that we started
building systems that were built were
designed with the theory in mind and
they started solving problems we
actually do communicate very effectively
with our data today and as a result we
took every piece of every artifact that
we were thinking we wanted to store and
converted it to data all our photographs
all the albums that we were thinking
about all music everything is now a
collection of bits and we are very happy
with the theory but as soon as you start
having this kind of a theory you sort of
suddenly realize this new rearm zap ah
Sybilla tease and all kinds of new
challenges emerge and I'll try to
explain to you some of these new
challenges that are emerging because the
old theories were exceptionally
successful so this is going to be the
reason why we will have you know the
second half of the talk at all the new
kinds
challenges that are emerging in the
kinds of solutions that were that are
possible I as you know the warning again
this is not going to be a very deeply
mathematical talk there is mathematics
underlying a lot of the things that I'm
going to be talking about but we I might
not be able to tell you much about okay
all right so let's go ahead and jump in
and I'm seeing the same problem again so
all right so what is this task no
challenge of reliable communication this
was a problem that sort of started off
in the 1940s the advent of the digital
age and until now we were really you
know we were communicating even before
but most of the natural forms of
communication were analog signals and
noise was something that we were hoping
our brain could filter out on its own we
did not have any active intervention to
work on the noise as a problem but in
the 1940s we started thinking about
digital communication and oops this
leads to sort of very interesting and
novel challenges it's no longer a very
continuous mode of interaction you make
one small error in the transmission and
you can get catastrophic changes in the
you know functionality of that message
and naturally messages and natural
languages are not designed to be
protected against minor single errors so
we have to do some active work and this
was the challenge that was undertaken by
the researchers in the off that era and
we will try to talk a little bit about
that so one could say well you know
there is some reasonable solution to how
to actually resolve this problem you
just repeat every message that we want
to send so if I want to send the message
we are now ready i repeat every letter
of the alphabet three times every letter
that i want to send three times and this
does work and after you do some
transmission maybe you get some errors
and these errors might you know
hopefully be distributed kind of nicely
uniformly everywhere but nevertheless
you can do some
entry calculations and this is the depth
of the mathematics that you will see in
this talk as long as the number of
repetitions that you're putting in makes
larger as you make it larger and larger
and larger the reliability of the
information that you're sending is going
to get better on the other hand as the
length of the message that you're
transcending becomes larger and larger
the reliability goes down there is
always a chance that somewhere one of
these letters you do see too many errors
okay when you put the two of these
pieces of reasoning together you realize
that the repeated the length the amount
of repetition that you have to put in
has to tend to infinity as the length of
the message also tends to infinity so
repetition suggests something which I
think was actually common belief at the
time at in the 1940s I wasn't there then
so you know you have to take this with a
grain of salt but the rate of repetition
means as you you have to put in more and
more and more repetitions depending on
the length of the message that you are
transmitting and so the rate at which
you're actually transmitting useful
messages is going to zero as the length
of your transmission goes to infinity
and this was possibly the the state of
the belief at those times till came this
beautiful work of Claude Shannon this is
the first of the and one of the most
impressive pieces of theory that has
ever been probably built is due to him
and this is his theory of communication
and Shannon said well let's look at this
problem and abstract it carefully what's
the first thing that you do you build an
architecture off a communication system
so before Alice sends her message she
has an option to somehow encode it
repetition was a way of encoding it you
sent everything symbol twice maybe there
are other ways let's just abstract it
completely and just say maybe I will
send K bits of information as some N
letter sequence how is this am I going
to go from K letters to n letters I
don't care
some function mathematically which
describes this map that's what I'm going
to use let me try to figure out what is
the best encoding function to use based
on the objectives if you've decided that
this is what you're going to do start
with some key letters and send some n
letters in our previous example n was
like three times K and we were not very
happy with that
we will try other choices later there
must be a matching decoding function
which compresses n letter sequences back
to K letter things and what you want
from this is the following expression if
I take some message m and encode it I
transmit it over the channel it will
flip some bits so let's say it adds some
error then you decompress it you bite
this decoder we hope that usually you
get back what was then we want this
message m to be equal to what was sent
with high probability and if we can
achieve this this is a good encoding and
decoding function its performance is
determined by the ratio K over N how
many symbols did I need to send in order
to get K things over now express in
these terms the prevalent belief of the
1940s was n is going to be super linear
in K it's going to grow faster than just
some constant multiple of K even if the
error probability was some fixed number
like say 10% of the bits are getting
flipped you probably have to increase
things but we can now ask the question
that was with the repetition what can
you do with other encoding and decoding
functions so what are the best ones and
best is determined in terms of this
performance measure the ratio K over N
what is it that we can get assume that
we want this error this probability to
be very very close to one sort of just
two he set that aside
Shannon asked this question and and came
up with this kind of a very remarkable
answer he said that if every bit for
example is flipped with some probability
P then the rate goes to this quantity
called 1 minus the entropy of the
entropy has this particular expression
the expression is not important except
to say well you know ok was a
closed-form thing you could calculate it
for any choice of p but he also gave us
the matching theorem this is the best
possible what does this entropy function
look like let's look at a couple of very
simple examples
if the bits are getting flipped with
probability is 0 i send you a 0 you
receive a 0 send you a one you receive a
1 nothing's getting changed i don't need
to do anything very sophisticated i just
send you the information that I have as
it is no need to do any encoding no need
to do any decoding you're fine you
should get a rate of 1 indeed that's
what this theorem promises if P on the
other hand as 1/2 means I send you a bit
which is 0 you're going to get 0 with
probability 1/2 a 1 with probability 1/2
if I send you a 1 you're going to get a
0 with probability 1/2 you're going to
get a 1 with probability 1/2 you don't
need me sitting standing around sending
your bits you can just simulate these
things ourselves ok you're going to get
a random coin no matter what I send so
you there's obviously no capacity in
this channel and this theorem indeed
insists that that's what happens but
what happens in between is even more
interesting sorry what's even more
interesting is that this rate that we
are seeing is going monotone decreasing
from 0 to 1/2 what happens beyond 1/2 is
not very interesting let's go up to this
point but even if the probability of a
bit being flipped it's like 0.499 it's
very very very close to 1/2 this theorem
is saying that there is a positive
capacity in this channel you can
actually use it to transmit information
and indeed actually people think about
settings maybe not as close to 0 as on
this setting but in engineering
applications we'd probably think about
settings where P is close to 0.49 as you
send off this satellite into space with
extremely weak battery so it's signals
that it's sending back
extremely weak or in a more interesting
experiment people were trying to
communicate this is just amateur radio
enthusiasts who decided to send signals
across the earth by bouncing it off the
moon so they send a signal over from
Earth it goes hits the moon and bounces
back so from New York to Tokyo you send
some signals this way and it actually
works you can actually recover
information that's all possible because
of these extreme choices of this
parameters even when P is extremely high
you have positive rate of information
transmission and the most important
thing the rate is linear in n so it's a
very creative solution not what we were
expecting at all completely
contradictory to the belief at the time
and it has the other aspect that I think
a theory should really help us with
which is it tells us what are the limits
this is the limit of the information
transmission you cannot do any better so
this was Shannon's wonderful theory and
I think so I do want to sort of talk
about some of the main contributions I
think the very architecture itself was
the contribution so the fact that you
decided to put in an encoder and a
decoder why is it so radical as a
thought well we are thinking about very
complicated functions that we are going
to build into this architecture of an
engineering system when the ability to
compute was zero weaned and no computers
at the time and not much hope that you
could implement many of these very very
complicated functions that we were
thinking about and yet you say ask the
question ok but suppose I was able to do
it
what would my limits be so somehow this
was a very surprising strikingly
different approach to the problem and
that led us to a beautiful theory which
eventually led all the practitioners to
chase the theory and eventually get to
the limits that it promised there's a
profound analysis may be almost an
independent discovery of the
probabilistic method it's not enough to
say whether this was actually true or
not there's these deep mathematical
concepts notion
of entropy mutual information etc which
give mathematical meaning to objects
which are very intuitive to us but turn
out to be actually you know concepts
that you can grasp with your
mathematical tools and analyze and even
though the initial theory was highly non
constructive I would say from the 50s to
now it has become very constructive very
algorithmic really really beautiful and
the you know the amazing thing about
this paper this that Shannon wrote in
1948 it was not just that he was
thinking about communication as an
engineering challenge but really as a
central challenge in the sciences he
really wanted to understand much more
than just how to build the next better
magnetic storage medium or an
information transmission mechanism and
here is for example an aside in the
paper which says well you know by the
way along the lines of this I can
actually build a series of
approximations to a language like
English and the AI father approximation
is built along the following way if I
give you the first I minus 1 symbols I
tell you what is the probability based
on just empirical analysis of the eighth
letter being some particular letter of
the alphabet and build on this model he
said ok let's see how it functions for
English this is a very non-trivial
challenge in 1948 he did not have a
random number generator I just told you
he did not have a computer and he still
actually gave us approximations so this
is a three letter order three
approximation from his paper pretty
interesting I mean you know this word
the monster's is not in English yet but
you know and then you know it gets even
better you know he decided well you know
letters are not taking me very far very
quickly but maybe I can build word
approximations and this is just a
second-order word approximation given
any particular pair of words it's sort
of there's a probability mass on the
third word and do you generate things
according to this thing and it starts to
look pretty interesting and
they're even more interesting is okay we
say okay all of this but does it have
any predictive power and what Shannon
actually observed about this which is
pretty interesting was that somehow I
thought approximation produces plausible
sequences of length about two I which is
some statement about English right it is
not something that I can either prove or
in any formal way but there is something
non-trivial it's a statement about some
restrictions of English in some
empirical sense so came up with all of
this in just this one beautiful paper so
this is a wonderful paper I could go on
for hours about this thing but what I
want to do today in this talk is really
talk about the modern theories okay this
was a great opening to the theory of
communication this is what our current
internet cell phone communications
storage media and their architectures
are all designed around and yet we
there's the next generation of problems
which are now we are encountering
because the first generation was so
successful communication tends to be
interactive so I could be you know the
two of us could be sharing a file
somewhere and we are doing some changes
simultaneously I send a thing saying
this section can now be deleted and you
think the section cannot be deleted
maybe that's actually a good way for
things to happen maybe I could have said
this section can you know I said this
section can not be deleted you interpret
it as it could now be deleted and then
you can make the catastrophic changes
all the changes that you do afterwards
would be errors in our dealing with the
file and it's not error is charged to
the computation to the medium of
communication it's just because of one
error at the initial stage of our
interaction so interaction leads to
major challenges and we will see how and
when to correct errors and there is a
collection of other things that I will
talk about a little bit more as we go
along so it is actually remarkable from
1948 till 92 we really didn't think too
hard about this question
what happens with interaction and it was
a remarkable piece of work
Shulman as part of his PhD thesis I
believe considered this question so how
are we going to actually start doing you
know correcting for errors in a in an
interactive setting so here for example
like in my example whoops we have Alice
and Bob interacting with a server a
typical interactionists of the farm
server tells the user this is what the
current document is the user tells the
server okay you know delete these
characters and certain these other
characters and so on and if two of us
are in acting on this simultaneously we
certainly don't want to have errors
which go uncorrected on the other hand
how do you when do you decide to correct
errors if you decide to look at the
first few symbols notice something is
going wrong what do you change it to it
could be that the minority of symbols
that are that seem to be an error are
actually in error it could be a majority
or in error maybe you know you haven't
seen enough this was sort of a bad
beginning but afterwards this channel is
going to stabilize if you decide that
you got a change in favor of one
direction now the entire interaction
afterwards is going to assume that the
first few symbols are the following if
you decide to do something else the
entire interaction might look completely
different which one of these
interactions should be even engaging if
you're not able to tell how to correct
you know so so there's always a
challenge should we correct errors
immediately why don't we wait for a long
time but if we wait for a long time
maybe we've doing the wrong interaction
all along so maybe I'll have to I'll
notice that there was an error in the
first couple of bits which should have
been fixed I didn't do it and as a
result I'm now going to have the penalty
of saying rewinding all this later
interaction that we did which is
completely futile we should have been
going in doing something else so this is
a very you know fundamental challenge
and even given the state of Shannon's
theory it wasn't clear how well we will
be able to address this for
a concrete question that you could ask
over here is again the same thing bits
that we are sending back and forth
between the user and the server etc are
flipped with some probability P what is
the rate of communication and once again
I think prior to Sherman's work it was
fairly clear to us that look okay if
you're interacting then rate of
communication is not going to be linear
it's going to go to zero as the length
of the communication goes to infinity
and once again Sherman proved us wrong
and the limits are not as well
understood as in the other case but
roughly what we have is that we can
actually still do very good
communication at a linear rate as long
as the probability of a bit being
flipped is at most one eighth and the
scaling is no longer one minus the
entropy of P something very different is
happening here it's more like one minus
the square root of the entropy of P so
something is different it's not quite
clear what but and there are limits over
here in upper bounds and lower bounds
these are some of the main folks
associated with this theory there was
working chill by Shulman in 92 and then
for a long time nothing really moved and
then in the 2000s till even the last
couple of years we've had a whole series
of results which have completely which
okay largely clarified this picture for
us so the moral of the story is even
when you are interacting and your bits
are getting flipped and many of much of
the theory holds even the bits are not
getting flipped by some random process
it could be by a very malicious
adversary who actually knows what you
planning to do to correct it
you can still correct this fraction of
errors and you might be interacting you
might be executing a protocol which is
interacting by sending one bit each time
all that is okay we can still actually
deal with a large fraction of errors so
very very pretty amazing and very
surprising I would say very surprising
even given Shannon theory obviously you
know if you just keep sort of
reinventing
Chanin surprise everything that I say is
going to be surprising but I'd say this
was quite quite a you know and the
mathematics that goes into it is very
very elegant very novel you really had
to shulman definitely sort of built out
a very you know striking theory as did
Braverman draw and so on all right so
now moving on back to my challenge with
the modern theory so interaction was an
element we deal with it I'm going to
sort of rewind time a little bit and
then go back forward in time a little
bit and interaction has another very
intriguing element very often we have
large amounts of inputs on both the
sender and the receiver and what we care
about is some joint functionality of the
two imagine you're going out to in it
and you know travel a travel agent this
could be an online travel agent and
you're trying to figure out what tickets
you could buy you have this challenge of
saying should I tell them all my
constraints and this could happen with
any you know online shopping experience
should you tell them all your
constraints and your preferences or
should the other side come back to you
with all their catalog of options that
are available is there something in
between where neither of us actually
sending you know doing a cold dump of
all the information by the way till
about twenty years ago we lived in one
of the two worlds mostly with the travel
agent we would just go up to a person
and tell them everything we want they
wouldn't tell us all the flights that
exist on the other hand with most online
shopping they would just send us a
catalogue of everything that they have
to sell and we would just read the whole
thing and figure out what we what subset
we may be interested in clearly there
should be something better that's
possible that's something that's a joint
you know takes into account the fact
that I might not be interested in
everything and you may not have to tell
me everything that you know so how well
should be modeled how should we model
this and how can we improve the
efficiency of this turns out that there
is a beautiful Theory do to you
which started to deal with these kinds
of questions so in this theory Alice and
Bob have some private information in
this case Alice might be the person
who's wanting to buy a ticket X somehow
represents all the kinds of preferences
and constraints that she has where she
wants to go what kind of price she's
willing to offer etcetera etcetera at
times and dates and Bob might be the
travel agent who knows about all the
airlines and all the information related
to that f of X might say give me a
ticket which is you know satisfactory to
me to Alice and in this model what Alice
and Bob do is engage in some interaction
and eventually produce the value of the
function that you're interested in and
the hope is that there is some mechanism
for communication which is lot more such
thing than sending all effects sending
all of why and nevertheless achieving
this function value and what we would
like to understand is what is the best
protocol what is the number of bits that
we really need to exchange in order to
be able to always compute f of X Y so
beautiful very simple model very
remarkably this has always been a model
for proving lower bounds we usually come
to this model and page 2 is these are
the things that you cannot do other than
by exchanging X or Y in this talk I
really want you to change perspective
and think of this as a positive model
there are probably games where we can do
a lot better and I'll probably try to
give you at least one example of that
now you can amplify this model have some
shared randomness it leads to a lot of
mathematical elegance to the theory but
it also turns out to have fair amount of
practical significance quite often this
randomness can be sort of you know dealt
with with some assumptions on the inputs
and so on
I won't exactly go into the details of
that but in general whenever you allow
Alice and Bob to use some common
randomness we will say okay as long as
they manage to produce the correct value
of the function with high probability
over purely the randomness this is a
good solution okay now as I said it's
usually
studied for lower bounds but I want to
think of it as a positive model so here
are some examples of some very simple
functions and I just want to I mean try
to come up with the simplest looking
functions for which you could actually
come up with non-trivial protocols over
here here is something that you can do
Alice might have some n numbers think of
them as real numbers x1 to xn Bob has
some n numbers y1 to yn they want to
know this some of the differences well
this is obviously a trivial problem to
solve you don't need to exchange n
pieces of information in order to solve
this problem I can use some laws of
arithmetic I don't know what they're
called and Alice can send to Bob the sum
of all the excise and Bob can just
subtract the sum of all the Y's from the
the information that Alice sent him and
that gives us the protocol two rounds of
communication very simple not n bits of
information so something much smaller so
you know really think of this as
constant communication so this was
trivial this is also I mean probably a
much too simple cannot possibly be
murdering very many interesting
scenarios but let's see how we can build
some changes now suppose instead of
computing the sum of the x i's minus y
eyes i want to sum of the squares of x
i's - y eyes ok already the problem
looks slightly different and in fact it
is different you can actually show that
this actually requires n bits of
communication no matter what you do so
it looks like it's hopeless but this is
why randomness is such a crucial
resource in communication if the players
are allowed to do things in a randomized
fashion then they have a very elegant
protocol so suppose Alice and Bob
actually shared n random bits which I
think of as numbers either plus 1 or
minus 1 Alice should compute the
following two terms s 1 and s 2
s1 is just a sum of the squares of the
excise and s2 is a linear combination of
the excise whose coefficients are given
by the r1 to RN Bob can compute the
exactly symmetric term and suppose they
exchange s1 s2 and t1 t2 so each one is
sending each other two real numbers and
you can do some finite precision
arithmetic to reduce this thing it turns
out and trust me if you accelerate the
following expression s 1 plus t1 minus
twice s to t2 this expression is of
course dependent on what r1 to RN R but
if you take the expectation over R sub
i's you get exactly the quantity that
you want so you just try out a few
different values of r1 to RN you get the
value which is sort of starting to
concentrate around this sum of the
squares and you've exchanged it so the
amount of communication goes down to a
constant independent of N and you are
now you know again this course relies on
the fact that the Alice and Bob share
some randomness but this is pretty
reasonable setting in many many cases
this by the way is a protocol which is
roughly do - I think alone Matthias and
Sega D actually pops up a lot in various
streaming algorithms and other such you
know sketching and so on I'm
interpreting it as a communication
complexity result which is really what
it is truly all right so going back just
I mean I'm not going to oversell the
application but really is this
particularly interesting I think knowing
in a approximating the distance between
points and n dimensional spaces is a
fundamental question in in the space of
large data and indeed I mean one could
easily imagine that I could express my
preferences as a real vector the travel
agent wants to express their preferences
as a as their options as real vectors
and we really probably want to say
what's the closest match to my
preferences that I have over there this
is not going to
I mean right now I don't know how to do
this for the travel agents thing but in
general this is a kind of a paradigm
that we've been thinking about a lot and
what this is saying is that you know
okay these vectors may be huge and this
n might be exceptionally exceptionally
long for us to be able to make sense of
it but but it doesn't enter into the
communication the communication
complexity is roughly twice as large as
the final itinerary something that I can
live with okay so imagine the kinds of
savings that this is promising if you
can implement these kinds of protocols
and it's not there yet we are not there
yet but I think we will get to the point
where every one of us will have an
assistant in our phone which is able to
take all our complicated preferences
expressed in English convert it to
vectors this is where we are going
anyway and we will start being able to
use solutions that look like this all
right so the drift that I'm trying to
get towards over here is the in the
presence of interaction there is new
kinds of challenges and new kinds of
efficiencies that are possible on the
one hand errors become much much more
you know important to deal with and deal
with early but at the same time there is
a challenge you can never ever deal with
errors too early all the errors may be
bunched up towards the beginning and
there is also the up you know options
that it's offering because we are doing
things interactively there may be very
creative ways of saving on communication
me sending everything I know to you is
not the only mode by which you and I can
interact this is something that we
certainly practice on a day to day basis
now a new kinds of challenge is emerging
to me which is related to the concept
that you know yes
interacting a lot of interaction happens
because the two endpoints are capable of
computing but if the two endpoints are
capable of computing they're also
capable of reprogramming themselves so
now there comes a challenge I am allowed
to reprogram my cells except when it
to communicating because when I'm
communicating I better have a protocol
that I'm sharing with you in common or
else the meanings of our bits are lost
or maybe there is a different way of
communicating in which I allow my
reprogramming also to have some way by
which I can you know learn how to speak
to you
so the Shannon theory typically works in
the original model you and I will fix a
communication protocol and never try to
try to work with this you know never try
to interfere with that the communication
modules are always fixed and I can think
about every other piece of computation
that I'm doing on the side well human
communication this boundary is very very
soft and we often end up with protocols
which you know trying to learn to speak
by speaking what is the meaning of a
word I I don't know I can ask you so I
want to think about problems that arise
in the in the in the interface between
the two and we will try to talk about
these two issues one which is can we
learn to communicate by communicating
and the second which is you and I when
we are communicating we are often
assuming a large amount of common
context like for example knowledge of
English some knowledge of mathematics I
at least did some probability
calculations with you all of these
things can I really assume can I write
down what I've assumed or would it even
be feasible for me to write down what I
assumed and expect a perfect
intersection with you so these are kinds
of questions that intrigued me a lot and
we've been working on it a little bit
and let me tell you a little bit about
it I'll skip the slide because said the
things that I wanted to talk so in some
work that I did with Brendan Juba who's
in here in the audience and so on we
started talking about this question can
we learn to communicate by communicating
you know how does Joe how do children
learn languages well they do it by
communicating they're not doing it I
mean there is some debate as to how much
of language might be hardwired into the
brain but certainly it's not
as much as you know the exact you know
the dictionaries are definitely not
hardwired and and computers don't seem
to be ever communicating along those
lines they always have this mode by
which they say part at least for the
next for today for the next month the
mechanism by which say my text messaging
will work will be the following very
rigid protocol in a month maybe I
updated but I'll update it with
everybody does it and then we are again
working in synchrony and so on so so a
nice alternate model would be where we
actually use the intelligence at the
endpoints this rather than saying let's
suppress it learn to communicate
according to what this the third party
who built the communication platform
told you to do let's learn to
communicate by interacting with each
other and is there a model which
supports this can we actually do this so
with Brendon and ordered girl Drake we
asked this question and eventually came
up with a theorem which says basically
that you can actually learn to
communicate provided the communication
is sort of verifiably useful so this
turned out to be I mean how to define
verifiably useful was perhaps much of
what this paper was about the theorem
was defined was nailed down at the
endpoint and we said okay whatever
definitions allow us to get here is what
we will be happy with but it also sort
of sends us a very interesting message
which can be actually made formally and
precise mathematically communication has
to be useful if it's not useful there is
no reason why I would be able to learn
to communicate with you there's also no
reason to be wanting to communicate with
you it better be somewhat useful to me
likewise you shouldn't be coming to this
talk unless you're hoping to learn
something from this talk so if it is
verifiably useful if I just give you a
sequence of random numbers and say these
are beautiful random numbers it's not
useful to you because you cannot verify
the claim if it is a claim that you
can actually verify on your own then you
can actually interact to learn to get
useful information from me it may not be
that we actually are in synchrony in
terms of understanding each other
perfectly where it will be that we are
in synchrony in a sense that you are
able to extract useful information from
me which is a very functional way of
achieving useful utility in
communication so this is something that
we are able to prove as a theorem I will
not dwell on the details of this of the
definitions over here another issue that
we try to deal with in later works is
computational devices are constantly
connecting context information and this
context actually affects communication
so for instance my phone in order to be
able to do a search on Chrome should
once the ability to do all of these
other things which I didn't realize had
anything to do with a you know using a
browser okay but it needs to for
instance pair with my Bluetooth device
it needs to know how to control the
vibration on my phone etc etc so why is
it gathering all this context and
incorporating it into a simple you know
browser functionality this kind of
behavior it might be surprising to us
and maybe actually not always the right
solution but it is you know Universal
and communication certainly in humans
you cannot possibly chop off the brain
into distinct portions and say these are
the parts that are aimed at hearing and
this is the part that's aimed at
speaking and they'll have nothing to do
with each other we would do not work
that way and that's not how we expect
things to work so context has some very
nice pros actually shared context
between a sender and a receiver makes
communication very epic effective and
efficient on the other hand it also
brings up new challenges if you have
imperfections of sharing of the context
this is going to make it hard for you to
understand what I'm saying
so shared context made today's lecture
possible if you didn't know English I
cannot give this lecture at all on the
other hand there is imperfection in the
sharing of this context I don't know
exactly what subset of English you know
and I don't can't write it down and it
may not be the same for all of
you yet it works so what are mechanisms
that we can extract in communication
that somehow have these two kinds of
features that you can analyze this so we
try to understand these things in some
work and this is a theme of work that I
call communication with uncertainty and
the two essential elements that we think
about over here our context should make
communication efficient on the other
hand there should be robust protocols
which allow this context to be shared
imperfectly there's a whole lot of works
that I could talk about for another hour
which I don't have but let me just sort
of tell you at least what kind of a
model could you use to study some such
questions then every turns out we just
go back to the yaw model of
communication complexity you know here
is a very perfectly nice model in which
you can establish these questions you
have some function left that you want to
communicate takes a lot of communication
to communicate this thing but maybe when
I throw in the context communication
becomes much more efficient what could
context be anything that I didn't
explicitly mention as an input to Alice
or Bob is context including things that
I've mentioned over here maybe the
function that is being computed maybe
the randomness that they are using
maybe the distributions of X&Y maybe
this was part of the assumptions maybe
other things which I didn't think about
but should be you know enable efficient
communication and when you take these
contexts communication becomes a lot
more effective but we would like
protocols where if these contexts are
not exactly matching FA is not the same
as FB RA is not the same as RB or the
probability distribution that they are
thinking about are not the same but
close in some measure of closeness you
get a little bit more communication but
not everything back this is the kinds of
problems that we would like to be able
to understand and analyze there is a lot
of work with a lot of people where we
talk about a whole bunch of such
problems and try to talk about you know
maybe you don't need common knowledge of
the distribution in order to compress
information maybe in human language and
communication we see that the dictionary
is a central element
but it has to does it have to be
designed centrally and exported to all
the users or could be somehow we
evolving in a dictionary on our own yes
it can be designed in a distributed
manner and lead to efficient
communication nevertheless things along
the lines of you know does the
randomness have to be perfectly shared
there's a compute function being
computed how to be perfectly shared
turns out none of these is actually
essential and there are ways around it
so these are some sample results it's a
sporadic collection of results not yet a
theory a thing but it also points to the
possibility of a theory contextual
communication and communication with
uncertain context seems to be a very
interesting theme in theory in
communication and I think is worthy of
studying so to conclude I think we saw a
sampler of some theories of
communication these have been extremely
extremely valuable in in the technology
and in the engineering side and in
addition to being exceptionally
practical and useful it's also I mean I
think the the the underlying mathematics
has been exceptionally pretty
there were many surprises especially in
the early stages but there is still a
big divergence between this theory of
design communication you know where
sender and user are jointly programmed
to be able to communicate versus the
theory of emergent communication which
is what we see with humans but also
increasingly I think devices are going
to be practicing this and can we you
know use some of this theory also to go
back and talk about human communication
just the way Shannon did with this model
of language and so on and is there
interesting phenomena to be explored and
Exploited over there so that's what I
have to say thank you very much
[Applause]
all right great thanks and then so I
don't know if everybody could hear the
question the question was we saw this
beautiful theory of interactive
communication is it ever being practiced
somewhere and the answer as far as I
know in practice no and why it's
conceivable it could be due to one of
two reasons there is no inherent reason
why interaction should be able to help
us a lot
anything that we might want to do can be
done when maybe two rounds or three
rounds
certainly the theory of computing tells
us otherwise but we don't see these very
many interactive protocols in practice
in general a second reason might be that
we were so fearful of the errors that we
decided to make all our protocols
minimally interactive and once you see
that you can do a lot more maybe we will
do things differently so certainly I
don't see us engaging with the user
server distributed edit model in this
frequent thing certainly when I'm
editing a paper with a collection of my
collaborators I tell them look I'm going
to be editing you better hold off let me
finish all my edits and then you start
this is somehow hampering my ability to
do interactive communication with the
full scope of possibilities but on the
other hand I don't know that we would go
to the extreme of saying let me allow
rapid interaction and take a chance that
the system is going to you know preserve
the file especially since most of the
papers are written one day before the
deadline
yeah so and you said that does that do
what
oh absolutely so when we spoke about the
encoding process and the decoding
process the interim process is what we
call error correction traditionally I
would think of anything that we do to
somehow cope with errors and error
correction process and it may range from
something as simple as expanding a
sequence and repeating it to ten times
something more sophisticated or in the
interactive setting something lot more
elaborate I tend to believe or even the
contextual setting anything that I do to
say let me see what you might know and
how to incorporate that I would call
that error correction there are not very
many you know the theory there is not as
well-established
[Applause]